Someone has to fight for what's right
like it or not we're walking the same
path the only way out of here is together
who missed me
you in let's go do something crazy
Welcome back everyone this is my daredevil
trailer video marvel just released it's
because they just took back all the marvel
netflix characters and shows to disney plus
i'll explain what this all means and some
changes that they made setting up bigger
things in the future marvel phase 4 marvel phase
5 on disney plus and just in the mcu in general
how did you just do that i'm a really good lawyer
so if you're brand new to my channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos and speaking
of disney plus quick shout out to my friends at
nordvpn who asked to sponsor this video normally
on my marvel episode videos i do giveaways for
disney plus memberships but some of you might live
in countries where disney plus isn't available
yet and you have to wait forever to get new marvel
phase 4 movies on streaming but with a vpn you can
actually change the location you access content
online from even if you live outside the united
states you can use a service like nordvpn to sign
up for the us or the uk version of disney plus i
know everyone's waiting for spider-man no way home
to hit disney plus you can also use a vpn to stop
anyone from stooping on your browsing history
which sounds like kingpin was actually using
bishop security for with those special phone apps
i'll add a link in the description below or you
can go directly to nordvpn.com emergencyawesome
so be sure to check it out they have a 30 day
refund policy just in case you decide that it's
not for you so some of you may have already seen
all the marvel netflix shows are on disney plus
now and agents of shield this is mostly meant
to be a daredevil netflix characters video luke
cage punisher jessica jones iron fist but i know
you all have lots of questions about what's
happening with agents of shield characters
since marvel is bringing back so many of these
legacy characters they were from shows that
were done by a completely separate group marvel
television before they folded that into marvel
studios and kevin feige took over everything and
then started bringing back the legacy characters
in new marvel phase 4 movies disney plus series
like daredevil and kingpin because we have already
seen clark grey come back as a version of coulson
earlier in the timeline so it's not unheard of for
agents of shield characters to come back into the
mcu movies in the future but marvel just released
this trailer celebrating the official return of
all the netflix characters you've already seen
daredevil come back in spider-man no way home as
his and happy hogan's lawyer let's see what he
has to say matt you're gonna need a really good
lawyer john favreau said that they shot so many
extra scenes of them just joking back and forth
because john favreau was a version of happy hogan
in the ben affleck daredevil movie i did a deleted
scenes video for that so i'll post a link for that
at the end of this and down in the description
below there were a lot of deleted scenes from
spider man no way home that didn't make it to the
digital release that i think that they're saving
for the home video blu-ray release so there will
be more daredevil deleted scenes that we'll get in
another month or so when they release that we just
saw kingpin come back during the hawkeye episodes
i also just did a separate kingpin deleted scenes
video with a bunch of extra footage you can find
the link for that in the description too when
they brought both of these guys back marvel
always films way more footage and scenes than they
need so there's a lot of good moments with both of
them that just hit the cutting room floor the way
that vincent denorio talks about the canon the way
they're handling this the way that kevin feige
talks about it the other marvel producers the
only things that they wanted to change about their
characters when they brought them back were just
like the visual design the clothes that they wore
but they didn't want to change anything else about
their backstories or retcon anything from the
marvel netflix daredevil episodes this is kevin
feige and vincent sinaprio talking about that talk
about organized crime in the marvel universe and
you talk about the cd underbelly of new york city
there is one primary character that comes to mind
he said i want to bring you into the mcu and i'm
not going to say no to that like that's pretty
awesome i really loved playing this character i
liked creating him kevin threw out the idea that
what if this could be kingpin we had talked about
doing a heavier set version of kingpin i love that
because i was able to explain how i feel about the
character and what what motivates the character
and fisk is really driven by emotion when they
brought kingpin back they even had him wearing
the exact same cufflinks from the marvel netflix
series kate bishop winds up using that coin flip
trick she learned from hawkeye to get him with
one of those cufflinks the reason why kingpin was
always so obsessed with those particular cufflinks
during the daredevil episodes and obviously during
hawkeye when they brought them forward was they
belonged to his father kingpin as a child wound
up killing his father and that's what set him
on the path to becoming full-blown kingpin
you may have also seen the recent comments
that charlie cox himself was making the past
week about doing a new daredevil series on disney
plus that's because marvel does eventually have
plans to do that it's gonna be a while but i'll
explain what's happening next with the characters
at the time charlie cox was mostly talking about
how he thought that would work within the tone of
the more recent stuff they've been doing on disney
plus like the moon knight episodes a little bit
more hardcore than say like the hawkeye series
but they haven't really done a brand new marvel
disney plus series that's full-blown rated r or
tvma like they did for the marvel netflix series
all the original marvel netflix series were
rated r basically like the tv version of rated
r or whatever they call that in the country
where you live but the really cool thing that
they just did on disney plus and this is a
big deal is they added parental locks and
brought a ton of adult content to the platform
in some countries they have a special separate
section inside disney plus so if you pay for
disney plus you just automatically go to this
subsection to find all the really hardcore
stuff punisher is a great example of this
the most violence most all-out crazy weapons and
bloody takedowns of all the marvel netflix series
and as of right now me posting this
video today punisher is on disney plus
so if marvel can put that on disney plus without
making any edits and they did not make any edits
to any of the marvel netflix episodes if they
can do that on disney plus marvel can totally
make a new daredevil disney plus series that
feels like it's in the same vibe as the original
episodes but which is way more mcu crossover
characters and plot during the original daredevil
netflix episodes the other netflix series they
did reference a lot of big events in the mcu like
the battle of new york during the avengers movie
they'd reference characters like captain america
every once in a while in really roundabout ways
but you were never gonna see a ton of those movie
characters showing up in the series in the way
charlie cox talks about it before spider-man no
way home he said because of all the weird politics
he and the other netflix characters were never
going to be in the mcu movies the one thing that
being in the mcu allows that we couldn't really
do in the with the netflix stuff is that i
can now interact with other mcu characters
um so i'd like that would be really cool
crossovers would be really is the thing i
would like to do next that was why during that
clip he talked about oh now we can actually do
way more mcu crossovers with characters and that's
what he's really excited to do in future projects
i've already mentioned this in previous videos
but he's not going to show up during moon knight
or ms marvel episodes those are the next series
they're releasing like moon knight episodes are
going to start in a couple weeks i'll be doing
videos for all them is going to be amazing but
later this summer they're supposed to release the
she-hulk episodes we don't have an actual release
date yet but matt murdock daredevil is supposed to
come back again during that because matt murdock
is a lawyer representing superheroes vigilantes
in new york city jennifer walters she hulk is
also a lawyer representing superheroes in new york
city it makes sense that they would run into each
other through the course of their work and also
separately as vigilantes at night as daredevil
and she-hulk they also confirmed that when he
comes back as daredevil like full-blown daredevil
in a costume the costume will be different it'll
be like an mcu redesign of the classic daredevil
costume we don't have any concept art for that
yet but you just have to imagine a much more
comic book accurate version of a daredevil costume
charlie cox was also recently making fun of the
ben affleck daredevil costume too just saying that
it sucks it was not a great costume daredevil and
kingpin are also supposed to come back during the
echo series next year kingpin did not die at the
end of hawkeye there was an alternate ending
deleted scene where hawkeye was supposed to
take the ronin sword and send it to kingpin with
a warning to never come after him and his family
or he would return and kill him ronan style in
this moment of echo shooting him in the finale is
right out of the comics kingpin only gets blinded
temporarily and then comes back which was meant to
be ironic because it was after he had tried to
trick echo into killing daredevil who is blind
it is supposed to feel like an unofficial
daredevil season 4 and they are supposed to
bring back other daredevil necklace characters for
that like foggy nelson and karen page iron fist
is really like the only netflix character that i
think that we will not see come back in a big way
maybe jessica henwick's colleen wing though we
actually found out she was supposed to play sheng
shi's sister in the shangshi movie but turned the
roll down because she had a scheduling conflict
and because she said if she became his sister in
the mcu she would not be able to come back in a
big way as colleen wing implying that the door
is still open for that and marvel's never going
to do this but my pitch for a new iron fist story
in the mcu is actually to make him the villain in
the shanxi sequels during shengxi we learned
that his mother's people from this alternate
universe worship this great protector dragon it's
kind of like their version of a celestial from
their dimension very powerful cosmic being the
iron fist lore is that he has to kill a dragon
plunging his fist into its heart to take the power
of the iron fist so you just have iron fist in
the mcu kill shangshi's great protector dragon
to take his power and then chung xi goes after
him for revenge you can get into the capital
cities of heaven plot from the comics and do
a cosmic tournament arc which is perfect for the
shangshi character he's a huge martial arts based
character what do you do with those characters you
give them a solid tournament arc but let me know
in the comments where do you want all the marvel
netflix characters to show up during marvel phase
four pitch all your ideas for how they come back
everyone click here for that brand new spider man
no way home deleted scenes video and click here
for my new ms marvel trailer video in easter
eggs thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!